Nobel prize-winning author Toni Morrison
has died at the age of 88 her family
said the celebrated American novelist
passed away peacefully last night
following a short illness Morrison
became the first black woman to live
than to win the Nobel Prize for
Literature in 1993 well let's get some
reaction to her death I'm joined now
from Chicago by the activist Reverend
Jesse Jackson very good evening to you
thanks so much for talking to us here
today I understand that you did in fact
know Toni Morrison so so share with us
your thoughts on hearing the news of her
death kevin has gained one very special
special woman a literary giant really
well yes and she I've seen her described
exactly that a literary giant and I seen
also tributes explaining how she
chronicled the african-american
experience in fiction over five decades
just how important a voice do you think
that's been over those years she
chronicled experience something real
death from sabra Jim Crow the present
level discrimination
political activist what the bread will
carry much flip to President Barack
Obama she was always grilling alone that
see it she wants an african-american a
female and and a giant whose work
transcended race and gender she was she
was a customer's artist yes and her work
has been on school syllabuses up and
down America hasn't it for years so how
important an influence do you think
she's been on on young people in the
country brother a Pulitzer Prize the
Nobel Prize that itself give us
distinction and it's all McGriff you
have American women have ever been
during the time of slavery Phyllis
Wheatley was savage from slavery and
began to write and became a phenomenon
Phyllis Wheatley it really says that
time we've had fewer but at the level
that Toni Morrison achieve in analyzer
so we said death we separate unlike
today in a big way indeed and not just
her storytelling but her extraordinary
love of language dispersed biscuit
became associate stolen science beat
balancing she was always curious kept to
it kept irrelevant
here is it and President Obama has
described her as a national treasure who
was as good a storyteller as captivating
in person as she was on the page what
was she like personally what was she
like in person either to me facing
always assured very self-assured suited
she walked in the room what was in the
room and not afraid to get involved
politically
analyzing Barack season and Bill Clinton
and and burning the the retardation of
the administration as well well Reverend
Jesse Jackson we really appreciate you
taking some time to reflect on the life
and work of Toni Morrison who has sadly
died thanks very much indeed for your
time this evening we appreciate it it's
kinda slammed at that the impact of
racial violence in this country
and what Trump has done has put us to
low global implication let's stop and
stop quickly okay thank you very much
indeed for your views tonight we
appreciate your time